I can't quite believe that three years
ago I began my life as a youtuber with
this video explaining that I had become
disillusioned with filmmaking my major
at school and wanted to become a
novelist the plan back then was to
follow the example of John Green who was
just then finishing The Fault in Our
Stars good morning Hank it's Monday the
vlogs purpose was to find an audience
for a novel I had written while living
in Paris and hoped at some point to
publish couple weeks later I came up
with the name here's my thinking I'm a
nerdfighter and a writer a nerd fighting
writer a nerd writer these days YouTube
is like the Wild West of media and even
the ones who've made it can't quite
conceive of their profession because
whenever they started doing what they're
doing it didn't exist at least that's
been the experience for me early on I
knew that what I was doing here as the
nerd writer was more exciting and
fulfilling than any other work in my
life but exactly what it was eluded so
today now three years later I want to
update the mission statement of this
project what we do here besides talk
with our hands a lot is cultivate
worldview I think those two words sum it
up nicely worldview is as you know a
particular philosophy of life it implies
the entirety of what we comprehend and
believe about the world about ourselves
about how each interacts with the other
it suggests a commitment a modest one to
the well-rounded individual the
intellectual life we at the nerdwriter
are men and women of letters as Terence
said nothing human is foreign to us we
recognize that life is philosophical
moral political financial psychological
artistic scientific and that what is
worth knowing is worth weaving into a
complex and comprehensive web that's
what goes on here at the nerdwriter and
it's a process that takes time I
research write film and edit this
project by myself in the free time I
have after working a full-time day job
but my dream is to do this with you
full-time I've set up an account on
patreon.com and today I'm asking for
your help to keep this project going if
you don't know what patreon is it's a
really cool wave
for fans to become patrons of the
content they love the way it works is
like this when you become a patron of an
artist you're agreeing to give that
artist a tip every time they release a
piece of content for the nerdwriter what
you can expect is three to four videos a
month maximum four so if you pledge $1
say that means you're going to be
spending somewhere between three to four
dollars a month it's important to note
that the nerdwriter will always be free
you will always be able to access this
channel and the videos here without
charge this is just for people who have
the ability and the desire to help
support this channel I don't want anyone
stretching their budgets if they can't
afford it for those of you who donate
one dollar you'll get a text mention at
the end of all my following videos for
those of you who donate three dollars
you'll get a personal typewritten poem
by me sent to your house for those of
you who donate five dollars and this is
by far my favorite you can get a limited
edition nerdwriter mug it matches
the mug logo at the beginning of my
video for other perk ideas I want to
know what you think they're for you so I
think you should probably have a say and
what they are give me suggestions in the
comments here at the nerdwriter we think
and speak critically dispassionately
precisely as we can we try to see the
world and ourselves for what they are we
try to think about how we would like
them to be and why it is we would like
them to be that way and we think about
thinking to here we cultivate world view
and I've had a good time doing
it so thank you and coffee on a Tuesday